my name is James Cole and I'm a medical
laboratory scientist at performed
testing in different departments of
medical laboratories my experiences led
me to update this model to include what
is known about the rule the nutrient
dependent micro RNAs play in linking
energy transfer to biologically based
cause and effect for comparison
behavioral ecologists tend to focus on
evolutionary causes some of them may not
know that behavior must link nutrient
dependent chemotaxis and phototaxis from
ecological variation to the physiology
of reproduction and ecological
annotations the behaviors that link
chemotaxis and phototaxis are energy
dependent that explains why physicists
chemists and molecular biologists linked
the epigenetic landscape to the physical
landscape of bio physically constrained
super coiled DNA they don't start from a
gene centric theory instead they extend
links from atoms to ecosystems across
disciplines that fact is addressed in
this model of biologically based
top-down causation I start with
thermodynamic cycles of protein
biosynthesis and degradation the cycles
link energy-dependent protein folding to
super coiled DNA the physiology of
reproduction links chromosomal
rearrangements to species specific
ecologically ecological adaptations for
example the bacterial flagellum is an
energy-dependent pheromone controlled
ecological adaptation researchers linked
to nutrient dependent amino acid
substitutions to the weekend evolution
of the flagellum which allowed
pseudomonas fluorescens to respond to
chemical
cuse associated with light feedback
loops length the chemical cues and the
light from chemotaxis and phototaxis to
the nutrient dependent resurrection of
the genetically edited out missing
flagellum amino acid substitutions link
the feedback loops to nutrient
energy-dependent immune system function
and the physiology of reproduction to
energy dependent amino acid
substitutions were linked to the rapid
development of a complex functional
structure that some behavioral ecologist
may claim evolved for contrast chemists
have since use femtosecond blasts of UV
light to stimulate nutrient dependent
DNA repair by a hydrogen atom transfer
in base pairs in solution the chemical
reactions link the speed of light on
contact with water from the
anti-entropic energy of the Sun to the
creation of nucleic acids which link
base pair changes to energy dependent
rna-mediated DNA repair the femtosecond
blasts of UV light can be placed into
the context of an astral biological
representation of top-down causation
that's how astrophysicists can help link
what has been reported in the context of
molecular epigenetics to rna-mediated
cell type differentiation my focus has
been on chemical ecology because two of
the most commonly studied
energy-dependent epigenetic
modifications linked changes in the base
pairs to rna-mediated amino acid
substitutions and protein folding by a
nutrient dependent DNA methylation the
energy energy dependent creation of
micro RNAs is the largest contributor to
epigenetic changes associated with the
structure of super coil DNA and healthy
longevity via methylation ecologists
cannot link epigenetic effects to
behavior via evolution if they skip
Schrodinger's answer to his question
what is life most of them also skip from
Darwin's nutrient dependent conditions
of life and simply claim that species
evolved but Schrodinger had placed what
is now known about ecological variation
nutrient dependent micro RNAs and
rna-mediated DNA repair into the context
of weekend evolution of the bacterial
flagellum he started with the sun's
anti-entropic energy and that's what
this model does the citations to
articles link the speed of light on
contact with water from quantum physics
to the creation of nucleic acids and
micro RNA flanking sequences the micro
RNA flanking sequences link nutrient
dependent hydrogen atom transfer in DNA
base pairs and solution to rna-mediated
amino acid substitutions and cell type
differentiation in all living genera
examples that link nutrient dependent
micro RNAs to rna-mediated events have
been placed into the context of this
mammalian model there are now more than
47,000 published works that link
nutrient dependent micro RNAs to cell
type differentiation in species from
microbes to humans in this model the
experimental evidence converges the DECA
peptide hormone can add a troponin
releasing hormone or gnrh links the
nutrient dependent creation of the micro
RNAs to the innate immune system the
nutrient dependent immune system is
linked to the physiology of reproduction
by a pheromone controlled systems
biology
and behavior food odors associated with
nutrient uptake and species-specific
pheromones control gnrh linked changes
in the nutrient energy dependent micro
RNA messenger RNA balance changes in
base pairs enable differential gene
expression in gnrh neurons during
developmental transitions the energy
dependent transitions are required for
successful nutrient dependent pheromone
controlled reproduction recent data
extends this mammalian model of
conserved molecular mechanisms across
the continuum of ecological adaptations
by a selection for phenotypic expression
associated with pheromones in human
populations a bit of a summary here the
term epigenetics is used to describe
heritable genetic modifications that are
not attributable to changes in the
primary DNA sequence in this model
epigenetic modifications link hydrogen
atom transfer in DNA base pairs in
solution from rna-mediated amino acid
substitutions to gene expression
expression the creation of genes and
epigenetic effects on gene expression
underpin the development regulation and
maintenance of all normal cells
nutritional epigenetics links all other
environmental factors from base pair
changes to micro RNAs adhesion program
proteins adhesion proteins and super
coiled DNA via our and a mediated events
so the key to this diagram is that
nutrients link the prenatal migration of
gnrh secreting neurons which allow food
odors and pheromones to alter the gnrh
pulse the gnrh pulse modulates energy
dependent hydrogen atom transfer in DNA
base pairs
in all body fluids the hydrogen atom
transferred in DNA base pairs links what
mammals eat to metabolic networks and
genetic networks during the concurrent
maturation of the neuroendocrine
reproductive and central nervous systems
via the physiology of reproduction sex
differences in behavior and other
behavioral differences in mammals so far
as I know there is no other model of bio
physically constrained protein folding
chemistry that links energy from
epigenesis to epistasis in species from
microbes to humans